DAVE ADAMS: OK.
Thanks very much for having me.
How's everybody doing today?
AUDIENCE: Good.
DAVE ADAMS: All right.
Very exciting
group we got today.
So we're going to talk a little
bit, everything about beer.
I first wanted to say, because
I just saw this guy walk in,
can I see your shirt,
sir, in the back there?
Can you stand up?
You have a Brewgler shirt.
That is amazing.
OK.
So I just wanted to get
that out of the way.
So what I'd like
to do is really we
can make the
presentation as technical
or is surface level
as you'd like.
What I really like to have
happen during these talks
is for people ask
questions, and that's
what makes it fun
and interesting.
I mean, I can sit up here and
talk at you the entire time,
but it's much more fun if
we make it interactive.
And if you have a
question about beer,
I'm pretty sure that
someone else in the room
had that same question or wanted
to know the answer for it.
So please ask anything
that you'd like to know,
and it could be literally
anything beer related or life
tips or facial hair
or whatever you want.
We can talk about
all that stuff.
All right?
So the basics are we're
going to talk about,
a little bit about the
history of the company, where
we came from.
I'm going to touch,
kind of sprinkle
in, the history of beer
throughout the presentation,
as we talk about ingredients,
brewing process, and things
like that.
Then, we'll move
into ingredients.
We'll then do a short talk
on the brewing process
and how those
ingredients are used.
And then, we're going
to talk about sort
of the mechanics of
sensory evaluation
and sensory vocabulary.
And then we're going to
break from the presentation
and go drink a bunch of beer
and do a live sensory vocabulary
training, and it'll
be really fun.
I'll teach you how
to talk about beer.
How many people in
the room have felt
intimidated at a
bar or restaurant
before, when they're
ordering a beer?
And you don't want
to sound dumb,
or you don't know how
to pronounce the beer,
or you don't know how to
describe the beer to a friend?
Or the server who's asking you
about what you want, and you
go, uh, I don't know.
I want it good.
Right?
We've all experienced
that before.
OK well, I'm going to make it
so you're not like that anymore,
and you guys are
all wizards when you
go to the bars and restaurants.
Sound cool?
All right.
I also need way more enthusiasm
throughout the presentation.
OK?
So when I say something
the next time,
you've got to give
me a little action.
All right?
OK, history of Green Flash.
So we opened in 2002.
We opened about
the summer of 2002.
We made very kind of
beach-going beers at the time.
We made a beer called
extra pale ale.
We made a ruby red ale.
They were all kind of
4 to 5 1/2% alcohol,
easy drinking beach-going beers.
We're up in Vista, if
you're not familiar,
that's about 35 miles north
of here, inland, off the 15,
and we're in kind
of a business park
there, where you see a lot of
the small breweries hanging
out.
About two years
into our operation,
we hired a new brewmaster named
Chuck Silva, and at the time,
IPAs were just starting
to come around and be
popular and present
in the beer community.
And Mike Hinkley, who is our
owner, he came up to chuck
and said, hey, I really want
to make the quintessential West
Coast-Style IPA, the San
Diego IPA that we can really
hang our hat on.
And then lo and behold, he made
a beer called West Coast IPA.
And if you guys aren't
familiar with that,
it's very popular West
Coast-Style IPA and one
of the first of its
kind that really helped
champion that style that
was sort of born in San
Diego and Southern California.
That terminology has been
used throughout the nation,
throughout the world, really,
about what a West Coast-Style
IPA is.
And if you wonder what a
West Coast-Style IPA is,
it means just highly hopped.
Lots of dry hop, which
means lots of hop aroma,
lots of bitterness, and a very
pale malt structure to it,
which that will all
make sense later.
OK?
In 2007, we launched a
beer called Le Freak which
was the first American
Belgian-Style IPA that
was inspired by
Hoopla and Chouffe
from Brasserie
d'Achouffe, and that's
been one of our most
award-winning beers.
We're actually going to taste
that beer today which is
awesome, very excited for you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVE ADAMS: There we go.
See, we got
something going here.
I like this, guys.
In 2011, we move from
Vista down to where
we're at right now, right
down the street from you guys.
We knew that there would
be a Google facility here
eventually, and we thought
we'd move down there.
So we started brewing.
At Vista, we're brewing
about 13,000 barrels a year,
and when you think of a
barrel, it's actually two kegs.
So it's 31 gallons.
The biggest keg that you can get
is 15.5 gallon keg, otherwise
known as a half barrel.
When you hear people talk
about the production of beer
at a major brewery,
they talk about it
in barrels, which would just
be double that, so 31 gallons.
So we made about 26,000
kegs or 13,000 barrels
at the old facility.
We distributed to
about 15 states or so.
Now, we are at the pace of
about 100,000 barrels or so.
So significantly more
from where we were at.
Right when we moved
into the building,
we immediately started brewing
at about 40,000 barrel a year
pace.
So going from 13
to 40, obviously,
that's a huge pain in the ass,
and it was very difficult.
But we did it, and now we
have a cool tasting room
and a fun place to go visit.
So come see us.
2014, we bought a
brewery that opened
the same year that
we did, in 2002,
called Alpine Beer Company.
They were known for
making, and still
are known for making, super
awesome delicious IPAs,
especially Nelson and Duet, and
we're going to have one of them
today called Windows Up which
is kind of a variant on Duet.
So for the people
that like hoppy beers,
you're going to be
very excited about that
if you haven't had it.
In 2015, we opened up
our barrel aging facility
which is called Cellar 3.
Cellar 3 is in Poway.
It's about a 20 minute drive
east of here, up one exit,
off the Scripps Poway
Parkway, right by the Costco.
Apparently, people like Costco.
I always have to
describe it that way.
I'm like, yeah, we're
about 4 1/2 miles up,
east on Scripps Poway.
And they're like,
yeah, I don't know,
and it's right off
of there, and it's
like, there's a Costco
across the street.
Oh, the Costco, of course.
I love that facility,
personally, on a personal note.
We use a rotating
art gallery as well,
and there's probably about 12
to 15 barrel-aged beers on draft
all the time.
Which is impossible
to find anywhere,
and it's very, very cool.
In 2016, we opened up our place
in Virginia Beach, Virginia,
which is awesome.
We did that for
shipping purposes.
So now, we have a
brewery on each coast
that can ship anywhere
that they need to ship.
And we also opened a super
giant tasting room there,
the beer garden is actually
the size of our entire building
over here.
So it's massive.
It holds like 3,000 people, and
a really fun place to visit.
So if you're ever out
on the opposite coast,
and you want to go check it out.
You've got a little home
away from home in Green Flash
out there.
And in 2018, coming
up very soon,
we're going to open a
place in Lincoln, Nebraska.
So we bought an old
defunct brewpub out there
and I'm working on the
construction right now.
And just hired a chef, and
we'll get our final inspection
later this month, and
hopefully we'll get going.
So if you're ever in the
middle of the country,
and you want to pop by,
need a home away from home,
we've got you covered there too.
All right.
Any questions on the
Green Flash stuff?
No?
Yes?
The Brewgle guy.
AUDIENCE: Why Lincoln, Nebraska?
DAVE ADAMS: Lincoln, Nebraska,
why Lincoln, Nebraska?
I could say, why
anywhere, and answer it
the same way, which
would be that we
want to be at a local or
regional brewery to as
many people as we
can, moving forward.
So we feel like there are
so many great breweries
in so many towns, nowadays.
Now that people are learning how
to make awesome beer, that it's
less of a draw to
buy national beer
when you have a bunch of great
breweries around your town.
And Lincoln, it's
a college town,
University of Nebraska's
there, and it's also growing,
building, beer community.
So we really like those
emerging beer communities,
where hopefully we
can get in early
and be a part of the community
and integrate ourselves.
So same thing with any other
kind of those types of areas
that we want to be a part of.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Do you brew the full
line up in both locations?
DAVE ADAMS: At
Virginia or San Diego?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVE ADAMS: We do.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat the question?
DAVE ADAMS: Oh, sorry.
The question was do we brew the
full lineup at both locations?
So the way that we decide
on the brew schedule
is just really based on demand.
So if we have orders, if
we have a bunch of orders
on the east coast
we'll most likely
brew them out of Virginia and
ship them out of Virginia,
and then the same goes
with the west coast.
And we do see a difference
in the mix out there.
If you take the
tasting room alone,
here, we have a bunch IPA
is at the top of our list.
And on the east coast, we have
a bunch of the darker beers
and pale ales and
things like that.
So it's definitely a different
audience out there that we see.
So the mix of the
production is slightly
different because of that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How much does the
water chemistry on each coast
affect the taste?
DAVE ADAMS: It affects
it significantly.
That's a great question.
The question was-- sorry, Adam.
I keep getting yelled at
to repeat the question.
I'm repeating it.
The question was how much does
the water chemistry affect
the flavor of the beer, and
the answer is significantly.
The minerality in the
water changes a lot.
It really changes kind of--
it's not a great term
for it-- but I would
say the softness of the beer.
The way that the hops, from a
bitterness standpoint and acid
standpoint, interact with the
minerals in the water really
effects of the overall
bitterness and sort of mouth
feel profile there.
So the water is very
soft over there,
and it is very hard over here.
And it's also a little bit
more difficult over here too
because we have
several different water
sources over here.
So it's hard to say what
the minerality looks
like in our water profile.
It's very inconsistent.
So we try our best
to level it out
with stripping out
some of those minerals
and making it consistent.
But the reality is,
if we had our choice,
I'm sure we would select to
make the water profile just
like the one in Virginia,
because we really like brewing
with that stuff.
But that would be triple
reverse osmosis over here,
would be a huge capital
investment to do,
but it's something
that we do want to do.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So softer
water softens the hops?
DAVE ADAMS: Correct.
Yeah, it's not as harsh of
a bitterness, if you will,
with the softer water.
AUDIENCE: Repeat the question.
DAVE ADAMS: OK, sorry.
I will learn to
repeat the question.
My apologies.
OK.
Moving right along, let's
talk about ingredients here.
So I brought some
agreements along with me.
Beer is made out of four main
ingredients-- barley, hops,
water, and yeast.
So I brought some barley.
We'll talk about that first.
I'm going to go ahead and
pass that around the room.
Here it is for everybody
to see on the camera.
The barley that you have in
front of you, when you see it,
is a two-row pale malt, and
that has lots of terminology
in there that I will
break down for you.
But basically, barley is
grown in two different types.
There's two-row and six-row.
And two-row, the
basic difference--
besides the physical structure
of the barley stock itself--
is that two-row
kernels, barley kernels,
are a little more plumper
and have a little more starch
content to them.
And ipso facto, a
little more sugar
content to them than
six-row kernels.
Craft breweries widely used
two-row barley, rather than
six-row barley.
Six-row is used by the
macrobreweries mostly.
So you'll see Anheuser-Busch
and MillerCoors and stuff
like that mostly using
six-row, as well as
they use some adjuncts
as sugar additions
that most craft
breweries do not.
So the basic mechanics
of malted barley
is that, well, first of all,
to get to the malting process
is very important.
So you grow the
barley, and then you
have to send it off to
the malting facility,
and this was--
I went to the Simpsons
malting facility right outside
of London, about three
hours outside of London,
and they've been
around for decades
and decades and decades.
The guys who showed
us around the facility
had both been there for 30
years, which is amazing.
So they've been
malting barley forever.
So basically, you're
going to grow the barley,
and then you hydrate
it in a giant vessel.
Fill it full of
water, hydrate it up,
then you put it into a
vessel called the GKV which
the Germinating Kilning Vessel.
So think about when
you're in school,
and you put a little
seed in your paper towel,
and watered down,
and let it sprout.
And as it started to sprout,
it was turning into a plant.
Right?
Well, that's the end of
the germination process,
as far as malted
barley is concerned.
So they stop the germination
process by heating it up,
and that's the kilning
portion of malting the barley,
and from there, you
have malted barley.
So that is-- what you see
right there is the lightest
malting of a malted barley that
you will get, most of the time.
It's called two-row pale
malt. Pale as in the reference
to the color, and two-rows,
because it's two-row.
Right?
After that, the way
that you heat the barley
is going to change not
only the sugar content,
but it's also going to
change the color of it.
So we've all seen different
colored beers out there,
from deep black to very
pale and strong color.
And those colors come
from the different malt
that they put
inside of the beer.
Now, how much they put
inside of the beer--
how much of that malt
or what color it is--
is totally up to the brewers.
And I will kind of dispel some
myths around the colors of beer
later on, but basically,
this malted barley
is our sugar content.
So by having this
special malting process,
we end up with this enzyme
inside of the malted barley
kernel that can convert
its own starches
into fermentable sugars.
It's extremely important.
So all you have to do is add a
little bit of hot water to it,
and then you have sugar water.
You have fermentable sugar water
afterwards, which is amazing.
It also has a lot of
historical implications,
because when we switch
from a society of hunters
and gatherers to more of
an agricultural society,
we use barley for lots
of different things,
like porridge and making
bread and things like that.
And as they were out
harvesting this barley,
one time it rained, and it
began the germination process.
So the barley had
basically malted itself,
or it started the
germination itself.
And then when they dumped it
into the bowl to make porridge,
they ended up with
malted barley that
sparked this enzymatic
reaction, and there's wild yeast
around us all the time.
So this wild yeast and
bacteria in the air
went in and fermented this
fermentable beverage that
was sitting in the pot
and started foaming over,
and they had beer.
It made beer, and
then someone crazy
decided to put like some reed
straw in there and drink it
and felt funny afterwards,
and then beer was born.
That was it.
So that was about 10,000
years ago, in ancient Africa,
and that's the most detailed
version of the history of beer
that you could
possibly get into.
So after this, the different
amounts that we heated,
again, affect the color
and the flavor of the beer.
They basically affect the
fermentable sugar content
that you're going
to have in there
and then what kind of flavors
that you're going to get.
So think about if you--
how many people cook at home?
OK.
Not like microwaving
grilled cheese,
like you actually could.
OK, so if you cut up an onion,
you throw it into a pan,
you're starting a
caramelization process, usually.
Right?
So the natural sugars
inside of that onion
are going to come
out to the outside.
We've all had caramelized
onions before.
And what happens is, when you do
it for a little bit in the pan,
you get a little
browning on the edges.
You get a little caramelly
characteristic to the onion.
If you do it for
a long time, you
end up with a deep, tan, rich
onion with lots of sugar,
lots of caramelly
qualities to it.
Right?
It's the same kind of
thing with malted barley.
So you can caramelize
malted barley very lightly,
and you can have--
it's called crystal malt,
and it has a wide range
of numbers, which is
a lovibond scale that
says how dark they are.
So a C15 malt would be
something that you'd
see in a normal IPA
or pale ale, means
that it's 15 degrees lovibond,
means it's very light in color.
And then all the way
to CE 143, that's
going to be that deep,
rich, caramelized onion
kind of characteristic.
And that's something
that you'd see in
like in imperial red ale or a
deep amber, copper colored ale,
and it's going to have
more sugar content.
Also, the longer
that you heat it,
the less starch
content that you get.
So then you end up with
a lower alcohol beer.
So a lot of times, people
think that darker beers are
stronger than lighter beers.
Right?
You've probably all seen that
before, heard that before.
Maybe you still
think that right now.
It's totally untrue.
OK?
And the reason why is because
the amount of malt that you use
is directly responsible--
with the sugar content--
which is directly responsible
for the alcohol content
that you have.
So for example, if I were
to make an imperial stout,
and I were to use
this glass right here.
I would probably fill
it up to about here
with two-row pale malt
that you see walking around
the room there, and then, about
that much of roasted malt,
and that's it.
Because roast malt
does not provide
a lot of alcohol content, but
it provides a nice, dark color
to it and a little bit
of a roasty quality,
because it's roasted like
a coffee bean would be.
And that is what makes
the alcohol so high
is using a bunch
of that light malt.
So if I were to take one glass
full of light malt and one
glass full of roasted malt
that was burnt to hell,
that light malt would
be a very strong beer,
and the dark malt would be
extremely bitter and not very
strong.
For example Guinness,
that's very dark beer.
That's 4% alcohol,
very light in alcohol.
So don't judge a book--
don't judge beer by its color.
How about that?
Book by its cover, beer by
its color, very important.
Any other questions on
malt before we move on?
Great.
OK, here's hops.
Hops are the popular,
exciting ingredient.
Right?
So I brought some hops
for you guys to check out,
but before I send those
around, what I wanted to talk
about is where they come from.
So they're grown mostly
in the Pacific Northwest.
Yakima valley Washington does an
enormous percentage of all the
hops that we get in America.
They're also grown in Europe,
Germany, Czech Republic,
the UK, and then they grow some
in the southern hemisphere that
are more similar to what we
grow in the Pacific Northwest,
like Australia and New Zealand.
Hops have a couple of different
really interesting components
to them.
One is that they have
anti-microbial and
anti-bacterial
qualities to them.
And the other is that they
have these acids and oils
that get extracted during
different parts of the brewing
process that can provide
different flavors and aromas
and mouth feels and all
kinds of different qualities.
And most of the time when people
think of hobs they think of--
what word do you think of?
You think of like a hoppy beer,
what do you guys think of?
AUDIENCE: Bitter.
DAVE ADAMS: Bitter, right.
You think of bitter, but it's
actually not true at all.
Hops are used for a
wide array of flavoring
and sometimes used just
for preservative qualities,
and it has nothing to do
with bitterness whatsoever.
and we'll get into that.
So hops are grown on
things called bines.
They're like vines
except for hops,
and they grow about 15
or 20 feet in the air.
And these bines, which
you can see right here,
this is after they've
been chopped down.
They get harvested about
once a year, one time a year.
Usually there's an early
harvest and a late harvest
and it's later in
the year, usually
around the October,
September-October range.
And what they do is they
come in with a thing called
a bottom cutter, and they chop
the bottoms of all the bines
off.
And then they come in with
a thing called a top cutter,
crazy, and they chop all
the tops of the bines off.
They put them in
the back of a truck,
and then they send them
off to a sorting facility.
And the sorting
facility is going
to try to get all of the
cones off of the hop.
So if you guys have ever
seen a hop cone before--
let me fast forward here--
this is what hop
cones look like.
That happens to be me
smelling them as well,
but you can see that there's
a whole array of hop cones.
This is after this bine
has been mulched up.
This is at the
same hop farm which
is called Segal Ranch in
Yakima Valley, Washington.
And these hop bines
will get stripped away,
and they all kind of
do it different ways,
but the idea is we
just want the cones.
They're going to take everything
else and turn it into mulch.
So once they get these
cones out of there,
they're going to send them off
to a kilning facility, where
they're going to dry out the
water, any remaining water
that's left in these cones.
And then they're going to send
them off to a baling area.
They're going to bale them
up into giant 100 pound bales
or so.
After that, most
of the hops that
are used at commercial
breweries are in pellet form.
So they send off these
dehydrated flowers
to these pelletizing facilities.
that grind it up into a powder,
shoot it out of dye, and then
ends up like this rabbit food
that I've got in this
glass, right here.
So I'm going pass this around.
What I'd like you to do--
you'll make a tiny bit of mess,
but I'm sure you guys
have some vacuums--
if you pull out one of the
little rabbit pellets in there,
and you smash it up real
good, and then you smell it.
That is called
volatizing the oils,
and like I mentioned
earlier, there's
two really important
parts of the hops which
come from one part of the sort
of anatomy of the hop which
is called the lupulin gland.
So if you ever heard hoppy
beers that reference lupulin
or lupulis or things like that,
that's all because of the hop.
Inside of the hop has a gland,
called the lupulin gland,
and it's this waxy,
yellow substance
that houses two important
parts called the resins
and the essential oils.
So in its most basic
term, the resins
are what create
bitterness and beer,
and they're judged on a
scale called alpha acids.
So it's about a
scale from 0 to 20.
So if you had a
20% alpha acid hop
and use all 20% alpha acid
hops in the boiling part,
you'd end up with a really
bitter beer afterwards.
If you didn't use any of
that in the boiling part,
you would end up with no
bitterness in your beer,
basically.
So it's very tricky to
when people talk about--
when people use the word--
Before I continue, my
least favorite word
in the beer industry is hoppy.
I just thought I'd let you know.
So if you say hoppy,
we might fight later.
So don't say hoppy,
and you'll learn
more of why I don't want
you to say hoppy right
now and also a lot more when
we do the sensory evaluation.
Because it's like saying a
beer is wet or alcoholic,
because it all has hops in it.
It all is hoppy to
some degree or another.
It just depends on how many hops
they use, when they use them,
what types of hops
they use, what
were the statistics of
those hops they used.
This is a very broad,
really crappy term
that doesn't describe anything
that has to do with beer.
OK?
So stop saying hoppy
for the rest your lives.
All right, moving on from that.
The other part is
the essential oils.
The essential oils are what
you're smelling right now.
So when you crush up that hop
pellet there and smell it,
that's because we smash
the oils inside of there,
and they all released
into the air.
That's called
volatizing the oils.
So if you ever go to
a cool cocktail bar,
and you get an old
fashioned or something
with a little rind of orange
or lemon or whatever on it.
And you see him squeeze
the rind on there
and twist it around
the rim glass,
you guys seen that before?
That's what they're doing.
They're doing the same thing
that we're doing right now.
It's volatizing the oils.
There's a bunch of the
essential oils inside
of the rind of the orange.
They squeeze it.
It shoots out, and then they put
it around the rim of the glass
so as you take a
drink, the orange aroma
is on the rim of the glass.
So that's what we're
extracting during the very end
of the brewing process.
So when you smell an IPA
or a hop forward beer,
in some way, shape, or form,
IPA, double IPA, hoppy pale
ale, whatever it may be, You
put your nose into the glass,
and you smell those pine and
citrus and grassy and resinous
notes, all those fun things.
That all comes from that
piece of the lupulin glands,
the essential oil of the hop.
Make sense?
OK, great.
There's about 150 or
so different commercial
hops out there in the world.
Then, there's a whole
bunch of experimental hops.
The Perrault Farms are the
guys who make mosaic hops,
for the people who are super
beer nerds in the stands there.
And they also run
the hop breeders--
I forget what it's called-- hop
breeders society, hop breeders
union, something
like that, and he
has maybe 10,000 different
varietals of hops growing
at their facility.
And they want to try to find the
next new Citra or Mosaic, which
are all cool, hip, and
happening hops, if you
don't know what they are.
And the time that
it takes from a hop
to go from what's planted in the
ground, this experimental hop,
to now it's as
commercially-viable hop
that everybody in
the country can buy
can be around 8 to 10 years.
So it takes an
extremely long time,
especially if you look at beer--
the craft beer as a whole is
kind of in its infancy.
Right?
We're only 25 years
old, maybe or so,
that it really
started ramping up
and really only in the
last probably decade it's
got very popular.
And now you see
commercials of people
that want credit cards
to open their breweries
and stuff like that.
That shit didn't
happen 20 years ago.
Right?
Nobody cared about
beer, so pretty crazy.
Any questions on hops
that we have out there?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What about this
area for growing hops?
What is you're
perspective in that?
DAVE ADAMS: We do not have
a great area for growing--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVE ADAMS: Thank you.
OK, now I'm back.
Hey, Adam, I'm going to
repeat the question right now.
What do I think about this
area for growing hops?
What are my thoughts on that?
Great question.
I think that this is not an
awesome area to grow hops.
We do not really have
the climate to grow hops.
If you actually follow
the parallels along both
in the northern
southern hemisphere,
you'll find that the
places where they grow
hops all follow
the same parallels.
So for some reason
or another, be it
the soil or the amount
of light that we
have throughout the
day, it's just not
an awesome area to grow hops.
Doesn't mean it can't
be done, but probably
just not on a massive scale.
It's already being done.
There are people that grow
local hops out in Valley Center
and Jamul and things
like that, but just
to give you an
idea, just for us,
which we're not that
big of a brewery.
The San Diego
location we probably
brew 70,000 barrels or
something like that.
If we wanted one
hop for one beer,
we would need 40,000 pounds
or so of hops to make it
a National Beer.
And that's probably
like 400 times
the amount that they
make in San Diego County,
and that's just one
hop for one beer.
So I think that, as a fun
hobby, you could totally do it,
and you could probably make
some pretty decent hops.
But on a massive
scale, if you're
to open up a giant farm with
acres and acres of land,
it's probably not
the best operation.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What else
are hops used for?
DAVE ADAMS: What else are
hops use for was the question.
[APPLAUSE]
Boom.
Great question.
What else are hops used for?
So previously, they were
actually used as a sleep aid.
So they would have
hop-filled pillows.
And in the history of
beer, they actually
weren't used in beer
for a long time,
up until about the year 1500 was
when they started getting used.
That's when they
were widely adopted.
Previously, they
used a mixture called
gruit which like a spice
mixture, similar to what you'd
get out of like a Jagermeister
or a fernet or something
like that, like spruce tips
and very herbaceous qualities
to it.
So I don't think that there is
any other real super popular
uses for hops other than
growing them for decorations
or using them in beer in
some way, shape, or form.
People use lots of
different ways in beer.
There's some fringy stuff.
Like people make air fresheners
out of them or Chapstick
out of them and things like
that, but for the most part,
that's what they're used for.
And part of the
reason why they're
difficult to use for
many other things
is because they can
be extremely bitter.
And especially
when they're used--
like if you were to
eat one of those hops,
it would mess up your
palate for a couple of days
or maybe just a day.
I probably should have told
you that before I passed them
around, but I mean, you're not
going to get hurt or anything,
but it just kind of
coats your palate.
You won't be able
to taste things.
So I see people use them
for flavorings and liquor
occasionally, hop-flavored
vodkas and gins and things
like that, but that's
really about it.
I don't know any other
commercial uses for them.
OK, the guy with
the Brewgley shirt.
AUDIENCE: I heard that this was
a really rough year for the hop
harvest, that there are a
lot fewer hops available.
Is that going to trickle down to
the consumer in terms of price?
DAVE ADAMS: The
question was this year
might have been a
difficult year for the hop
harvest, the amount of
hops that were harvested,
and is that going to affect the
price of the beer for the end
consumer?
Throughout the years,
we have not really
seen downward price pressure
from the consumer side because
of the ingredients.
Which kind of sucks
for us, because it's
very dissimilar from the
wine industry in the sense
that when you have a
bad year of grapes.
You can just say our
wines suck that year,
because we had a
bad year of grapes.
But in beer, nobody really
thinks of it that way.
All of you guys
that drink our beer,
or any beer for that
matter, you expect
it to taste exactly the same
every time you drink it.
Right?
You don't go buy your favorite
IPA or pale ale or sour beer
or whatever it is
and go, wonder what
it's going to be this time.
Who knows?
Right?
That doesn't happen, and that
is the way that it is with wine.
Right?
You see that thing on
the label like 2002
is better than 2006 is
better than 2009 or whatever.
We don't really have that
opportunity, most of the time.
So pretty much everyone
expects the beer
to be the exact
same price and have
the exact same flavor and
aroma and qualities to it,
no matter what.
So we're not really
afforded that capability
of changing the price point
because of the ingredients.
You either don't make
that beer anymore
or use substitute hops
that maybe had a better
harvest or things like that.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So if my
friends say a beer is
hoppy, if I want to sound cool
do I correct them and say,
[INAUDIBLE].
DAVE ADAMS: No, you don't.
The question was if my
friends say a beer is hoppy,
and I want to be cool and
correct them, do I say
something else.
I think that I am a huge
proponent of education
and educating people
and especially when
it comes to things that
there's lots of bad information
that's out there.
Which I think the
beer industry is
one of those things,
where it's starting
to become more prevalent
that people know more things.
There's more good
information floating around.
But for a very long time, we had
lots of bad information, lots
of people making up things and
acting like sort of authorities
on subjects they
probably shouldn't have
been which helped the
spread of poor information,
unfortunately.
And then we ended up
with things like people
calling everything hoppy.
Right?
So if your friend says, I
think this beer is hoppy,
and if they really care,
and they want to learn more,
then you can tell
them what you learn
at the end of this, when we
talk about sensory evaluation.
If they don't care, then
just don't correct them.
It'll save you a friend.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: What are the
physical effects of hops,
like compared to alcohol.
DAVE ADAMS: The
question was what
are the physical effects of
hops compared to alcohol.
I don't know if I
understand the question.
AUDIENCE: Well, you get drunk if
you drink alcohol, but is there
any kind of relaxation or--
DAVE ADAMS: So yes.
The question was is there
some sort of physical effect
that you can feel from hops?
It was, I suppose,
pontificated that it
could be a relaxant
of some nature,
that it could make you sleepy
in some way, shape, or form.
And some people
do claim that when
they drink heavily hopped
beers, they become more relaxed.
They become more sleepy.
Like I mentioned, they used
them in pillows previously.
People who work
the hop farms, they
would say that
they'd fall asleep.
So I suppose that
there's something there,
but I personally don't
notice any effects.
So I don't know.
That's all I got.
What else?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
like mosaic hops that
came from the Yakima Valley.
Are certain hop varietals
particular to a grower,
like mosaic can only be
purchased from that grower?
DAVE ADAMS: Yeah.
The question was are there
particular hop varietals
that are out of--
you can only get from one
grower, and the answer is yes.
And it's actually a
very important part
of understanding hop purchasing,
because when hops are made,
most of the time, the farm
wants to own that hop.
So nowadays, everybody
has these like name brand
hops that they want to make
only at their hop farm.
You can only get them
at their hop farm.
They do license out the
names, and eventually
usually, they end up
growing them other places.
And saying you know this is
mosaic, but it's trademarked,
and it came from Perrault
Farms originally.
And then there was some
shake up awhile back
where-- like the hop that
you guys got to smell
is called Columbus.
At that time, there were several
farms growing that same hop,
and it was Columbus, it was also
Zeus, and it was also Tomahawk.
And so you could buy
Columbus, you could buy Zeus,
you could buy a Tomahawk,
and you could buy CTZ.
It's all the same
hop, but so that
got really messy and
really confusing.
So we don't see
that much anymore,
but yeah, there's definitely
trademark issues out there
with hops.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does anyone
try to make vintage beer?
Like you mentioned [INAUDIBLE].
Does anyone do that?
DAVE ADAMS: Yeah.
Lots of people do
it, and it only
is usually done with barrel-aged
beers most of the time or beers
that have extreme aging
properties that are not hop
forward, like imperial
stout or a barley wine
or some sort of sour beer,
something along those lines.
Yeah.
We can talk about that more.
OK, anything else on hops?
Great.
Oh, there's the inside of a hop.
That's cool.
So this waxy stuff--
It's a little hard to
see with the projector--
but there's little yellow
dots all over this.
You can kind of see
it in this region.
That's the lupulin gland
that I was talking about.
So if you were to take a
hop cone and smash it up,
it's real sticky.
And it would have all those
little yellow balls around it,
and that has all the resins
and the essential oils.
OK, let's talk about water.
We talked about it a little bit,
about the minerality of water.
The important things that
I want to note on water
is that the mineral content.
Number one, it affects the
quality of the beer quite a bit
and the qualitative
part of the beer,
and also the quantitative
part of the beer
in some way, shape, or
form in regards to the hops
and how they interact.
But also that we have
to reduce the hell out
of the beer to get it
to where it needs to be.
So usually we use about five
times the amount of water
that it is equal to liquid.
So if I had this bottle of
water, and I was making beer,
I would need five times
the amount of liquid
in here to make one
glass of beer that
was equal to this bottle.
So it takes a lot of water
to make beer, in other words,
and then if you were to do
something like reverse osmosis,
it takes exponentially more
water in order to do that.
The other thing to
note about water
is that the regions that
have different minerals
in their water.
Before, we could strip
the minerals out of water
and adjust the minerals, and
we had chemistry and science
and all these things.
The type of water really sort
of chose the type of beer
that you made.
So if you were in Pilsen, for
example, you made pilsner,
because the water was
super soft and it's
great for making pilsners.
If you were on Burton
upon Trent in England,
you would make an ESB, because
the gypsum in the water
interacts with the
hops and makes a really
cool characteristic of them.
So you still see, especially
in the old world countries,
those people that have made--
and especially
people that didn't
have to go through
prohibition was a big thing.
Because we had like a little
break in beer making process
for 11 years, and a lot
of other people didn't--
so those people, the water
profiles really shaped
what styles of beers they made.
As well as the temperature,
because that really
changed whether you
use lager or ale yeast,
because there's a
big difference there.
But those are the main
qualities of water,
and other that that, water is
really boring to talk about.
So I'm going to
move on, unless you
want to know more about water
in some way, shape, or form.
OK.
This is what it looks like,
if you haven't seen it before.
All right.
OK.
So there's some gypsum.
This is if you had a
commercial brewery,
you'd have some
pallets of this stuff.
You can rip them open,
adjust the mineral content
inside of your beers,
depending on what type of beer
that you're making.
So let's say,
generally speaking,
you want to make a light lager.
You would make the water as
soft as possible least mineral
content.
And if you were making
a hop forward beer,
you would use lots of minerals
in there to interact with hops.
OK.
Yeast.
So yeast I think is
very fun, and it's also
kind of the unsung
hero of beer, and it's
where a lot of the
qualities of beer come from.
It's maybe a boring
topic to the uninitiated,
but when you learn of
all its magic qualities,
you guys will be very
excited about yeast.
So there are two
different types of yeast
out there in the world,
and they are what?
AUDIENCE: Ale and lager.
DAVE ADAMS: Boom,
ales and lagers.
That means there's two
different types of beer
out there in the world.
So if you ever thought there was
like a million different types
of beer, there isn't.
There's just two.
It's ales and lagers.
The difference between the
two is that ale yeast--
so they both produce
three qualities.
I should say that first.
They both produce
CO2, esters, and--
AUDIENCE: Alcohol.
DAVE ADAMS: Alcohol, right,
the thing we all love.
Wait, what?
So these three qualities are--
they flow through both
of these types of yeast,
but the ester
production in ale yeast
is very extreme, as to where the
ester production in lager yeast
is almost nonexistent.
What are esters, you
may be wondering.
Esters are natural, fruity
compounds and flavors
that come out during
the brewing process,
and it's really what makes
yeast kind of the unsung hero.
Besides making all the alcohol
in the beer, like I'm sure we
probably, none of
you, would drink beer
if it didn't have alcohol in it.
But besides that, a lot
of the flavors and aromas
that you get out of beer
come from the yeast.
And a lot of the specific
styles that you like,
if they didn't use the
yeast that they did,
then they wouldn't be
that style of beer.
So think about it this way.
If you were to have a
true German hefeweizen
like from Ayinger, Francis
Kahn, or something like that,
they use a German weizen yeast.
And that has a special kind
of clove and banana-like aroma
that comes from the yeast
only, just from fermentation
those qualities
naturally come out.
They don't add
any bananas to it.
They don't add any clove to it.
That's all it is.
If that beard did not
use that type of yeast,
it would not be that beer.
Same thing goes
with Belgian beers.
How many of like Belgian
beers in the room?
OK, and I'm talking
about real Belgian beers
like Trappist-style beers,
Belgian quadruples, triples,
doubles, all that kind of stuff.
Those types of beers use a
special type of yeast strain
that has a banana
quality to it, that
comes out during the
fermentation process.
So all the beers that
you try in that category
are all going to have, basically
speaking, that type of aroma.
Without that, it's
not that type of beer.
So yeast really makes
the beer what it is.
Without that type of yeast,
without that special type
of yeast--
and you could use a
different type of yeast,
and it would be a
totally different beer.
If I took the entire recipe
for a Belgian-style quadruple,
and I used a English
ale yeast on it,
let's say, it would
not taste anything
like a Belgian quadrupole.
And you would wonder
why I made this beer
and called it a
Belgian quadruple.
So very important that we use
the correct types of yeast,
and there's hundreds of
different types of yeast
out there.
So the ale yeast works
from about 68 to 72 degrees
Fahrenheit, and lager
yeast works from about 45
to 55 degrees Fahrenheit.
And lager yeast, a lot of times
people think that lagers--
what do you think
of when I say lager?
AUDIENCE: Budweiser.
DAVE ADAMS: Yeah.
You think mostly like lighter,
easy-drinking American adjunct
lagers--
Bud, Miller, Coors,
things like that.
But the reality of
the situation is
you can use whatever
type of yeast
that you want in whatever
type of beer that you want.
So if I made this
crazy imperial stout,
and I wanted to put a lager
yeast on it instead of an ale
yeast, I could totally do that.
And it'd be a very strong
and aggressive dark beer,
but it would just not
have the same esters
that the ale yeast would have.
So like a Baltic porter
is a great example.
Baltic porter is about a
8% to 10% imperial porter,
black in color, but
it uses lager yeast,
so a little bit different.
Right?
Different aromatic
qualities because of it.
So don't write off
lagers, because they're
lagers, and don't write off
beers because of their color.
OK?
There's two things to
walk away with this from.
Any questions on yeast?
Oh, you know what
else I should say?
Sorry.
That the amount of time that it
takes to ferment the product.
So for ale yeast, it
takes about one week
to ferment out a
product, from start
to finish, and lager yeast, it
takes about a month and a half.
So a significantly
different time
because of the different
operating temperatures.
What was your question?
AUDIENCE: Does
White Lab still do
that tasting thing where they
same recipe different yeast
[INAUDIBLE]?
DAVE ADAMS: So the question
was does White Lab still
do a tasting panel
with different worts
that they put
different yeast on,
and I believe the answer is yes.
White Labs, if you don't
know, is a yeast facility
that's up off of Miramar
Road, fairly close to us,
if you're in San Diego.
So head out there.
Check it out.
It's really cool.
Wort is basically the beer
that hasn't had yeast on it yet
and hasn't turned into beer.
So they'll make
one type of wort,
like let's say a pale
ale wort, and they'll
put a German weizen yeast on
it and a Trappist Belgian-style
yeast on it and an
English ale yeast on it
and an America yeast on it.
And that way you can see what
those different qualities
are that I'm talking about,
in regards to esters.
It's actually a really cool
little science experiment.
OK, any other
questions on yeast?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I've heard
that White Labs produces
itself the majority of
brewers yeast that's
used for craft breweries.
Is that true?
DAVE ADAMS: The
question was does
White Labs produce the
majority of yeast that's
used for craft breweries?
I don't know.
There's also Wyeast,
and there's also Omega,
and they both make quality
products that are used.
I think that maybe on the west
coast White Labs is used more.
I think Omega and Wyeast are
used more on the east coast,
and we're starting to see people
switch over to those especially
for barrel-aged beers and sour
beers and things like that.
I think for American ale yeasts
and California ale yeasts
and stuff like
that, you'll still
see a lot of White Labs
canisters and breweries.
OK?
What else?
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: What's the scale
of your yeast purchases,
for 50 barrels, let's say.
DAVE ADAMS: That's
actually a good question.
What's the scale of yeast
purchases for 50 barrels?
So what we do, and what
most breweries will do,
will actually be to buy a
pitchable batch for a much
smaller batch and then
we'll propagate it up
to build it up to
a bigger batch.
So we usually brew 250 barrel
tanks, or 500 kegs at a time.
Our brewhouse is 50 barrels.
So we 5 times into the
fermenter, but what we'll do
is divert an amount
of wort, usually
about 100 barrels, 80 to
100 barrels, into a smaller
fermenter.
We'll pitch that yeast
in there, let it build up
to 100 barrel batch, and then
we can pitch it into the 250
after that, and we can reuse it.
For about 10
generations, it still
has the amount of cells
that we need to reuse it
for that amount of time.
After that, it starts
mutating, and it
doesn't have the qualities
that we want it to anymore.
So we have to toss it
out, but pretty cool.
We can use it a bunch of times.
Any more questions?
OK.
Oh, that's what yeast looks
like, little fluffy balls
of joy.
OK, let's talk about the brewing
process, so one slide here.
So all of the ingredients
that you learn,
we'll talk about how
to use them real quick.
So in the top right corner
there, you'll see the mill.
So what we do is we take all
that malted barley, whatever
we're going to use
to make the beer,
be it all two-row pale malt or
a mixture of 10 different malts,
whatever we want to do, we
grind it all up in a mill.
So the way that you see
that bag that came around,
that is how the malt
comes to us basically.
And then we put it
inside of this mill that
grinds it up and cracks
into the kernels for us,
and the reason why is so we can
access those starches much more
easily and the enzymes
that are inside of it.
So we crack it up,
we get it inside
of the first vessel, which
is called the mash mixer.
So if you're in a smaller
home brew kind of operation
or a smaller
brewery, you'll have
a mash up like a mash-lauter
combo, where you'll see
something called the mash tun.
In a larger, more
commercial brewery,
you'll see those
two tanks separated.
So at our brewery, this
is what it looks like.
The mash mixer is
the tank where you
spark the enzymatic reaction.
So you dump all the
malted barley in there,
you hit it with your hot
water, you spin it around.
If you were making
it at home, you
do it on a big pot on the stove,
and you just churn it around
with a spoon.
That's all you'd have
to do, and that's
the mash mixer part of it.
After that, we're going to take
everything inside of that tank
and put it into the lautertun.
The lautertun is
the tank where we're
going to extract the malted
barley out of it, because we
don't need it anymore.
We only need it for the
very first step in order
to get all of the
fermentable sugars out
of it and all the colors
that we wanted out of it.
So we do a couple of different
things in the lautertun.
Those little dots
on the bottom of it,
those actually represent
a false bottom.
So it has a bunch of
actually slots through it
and grates over
the top, and that
allows the liquid to seep
through the bottom of the tank.
And the grain will stay
on the top of the tank,
and then at the same time, we
will do what's called sparging.
Sparge means to rinse, and
we are going to rinse off
each of those barley kernels.
We're also going
to be adding water,
so we can reduce it later on.
We get those reduction
of flavors going.
So we add a bunch
of water in there,
we rinse off all
those kernels so we
can get every little
piece of sugar
that we possibly can off
there, and then it heads over
to a boil kettle after that.
There's a couple of
different ways to boil.
You can either use
direct fire, that's
what you'd use if
you were at home,
and you had a little jet
burner, a little stand
burner that you put the pot on.
At a commercial brewery, most
of the time you use steam.
So that little unit inside that
has the number three on it,
that's called the calandria.
And inside of that calandria
is a series of about 100 tubes,
and they're all heated by steam.
And what happens
is the wort sucks
in through the bottom
of that calandria
and kind of gets flash boiled
by each of those metal tubes.
And then it hits that top hat
and boils out onto itself.
So it constantly goes
up through the middle
and boils out to the outside.
That way we can get a nice
even rolling boil going.
You know when you're
making pasta at home,
and it starts bubbling
and really going,
that's a rolling boil.
So we want to get that going.
It's very important
to get that going
for three different reasons.
One is we're going to sanitize
the beer, very important
so we don't die that we drink
the beer that is sanitized.
It's also why-- a big
reason, historically,
why we're all
still alive today--
it's also why the Mayflower
landed where it did.
So it's very important
back in the day
that you had beer
on your adventures,
and part of the reason
was because the water was
filled with dysentery and
other bacteria contamination.
So if you had water, and
that was the only thing
you had to drink, you died.
And if you had beer--
they didn't know
it at the time--
but it was sanitized
through the boiling process,
and because of the yeast
that was in there, creating
alcohol and things like that.
So everybody drank beer, because
you drink beer, you live.
You drink water, you die.
So it was a very
easy proposition.
Right?
So most of the time,
the beer back then,
what we think of as the beer
now is a very social structure
to it.
We go out to the bars.
We go to the tasting rooms.
We hang out with our friends.
We geek out.
We yell at our friends for
using hoppy, things like that.
But back then, it was 2% 2 1/2%.
The kids drank it.
Parents drank it.
Everybody drank it, because
it had vitamins, minerals,
and sustenance, and it didn't
kill you, very important part.
So we boil it, so it don't
die, first of all, sanitize it.
The second part is so we can
get a reduction of the flavors,
which we talked about.
Just like you're
making a nice wine
sauce on your stove at home,
we want to reduce the flavors,
so we can intensify them,
same idea that we're doing.
And then the third
reason is because we want
to interact with these hops.
So when we put the hops
in, right at the beginning,
you're going to get the
part of the lupulin gland
that has the resins in it
is going to be extracted.
They're isomerized
in boiling liquid,
or they become water soluble.
So that breaks down
the acids in the hops,
and it returns bitterness.
So if you want to make
a super bitter beer,
then you add a bunch
of high alpha acid
hops at the very
beginning of the boil,
and you end up with
a lot of bitterness.
If you don't want
as much bitterness,
then you can do two things.
You can either use a hop that
has a lot lower alpha acid,
a lot lower level
of bitterness, maybe
4% or 5% alpha
acid instead of 20,
and you can dump them in then.
Or you can just not do
a first hop addition
and do them later
on in the boil.
Because the less
time that the hops
have to break down
in this rolling boil,
the less of the acids that
they're going to extract.
A tricky part about
the boil though,
is that the essential oils
are extremely delicate.
So all those beautiful
flavors and aromas
that come out from
the essential oils
that we got to
smell earlier, those
will get boiled off really
quickly when you use them
in the first part or for
the majority of the boil.
When you're home brewing,
and things like that,
you'll hear a lot of terms
like late edition hops.
That means that you
do it at the very end
of the boiling process.
That way you get the most
essential oil extraction
that you can.
You get the most
aroma that you can.
After that, we do another
step called the whirlpool.
In the whirlpool, the wort
will shoot in at an angle
and spin around in a
circle, just like whirlpool.
Before that happens,
especially if we're
making a hop forward
beer, we're going
to put a big bed of hops
inside of that whirlpool.
And it's going to spin around
and pick up all those hops
throughout, and
it's going to create
some nice flavors,
some nice aroma,
we'll get a little color pick
up from it spinning around.
We're not actively
boiling during this part,
it's in the low 200
degree Fahrenheit range,
and then we're going to
get rid of it from there.
So this is called the hot
side or the brew house.
A lot of people think
that the fermentation area
is the brewhouse, but
this is all called
the hot side or the brewhouse.
It's where all the stuff
on your stove at home
would happened, basically.
After that, we're going to move
all the wort into the cellar.
The cellar is where
the magic happens.
That's where the
yeast gets introduced.
That's where beer becomes beer.
Because all the brewers do
is make hoppy sugar water,
and then the yeast makes beer,
very important to remember.
Whenever brewers are
feeling high and mighty,
just tell them that, and they
get real sad, real quick.
So the last thing
is that little grate
at the bottom of the
whirlpool is a heat exchanger.
So we want to make the 210,
212 degree hoppy sugar water 72
degree hoppy sugar water,
so we can ferment it over
on the other side.
We don't have mass
genocide of our yeast
when we go put it over there.
Because we put 200 degree
wort inside of this fermenter
with a bunch of yeast, they'd
all die and be real sad.
So we don't want that.
We put it over there, and we get
it to 72 degrees very rapidly,
takes just a couple of minutes
to get it down that quickly.
And then when we get it
inside of the fermenter,
we dump the yeast inside of
there, and we let it go crazy.
Very important that
there's little oxygen
pick up during this process.
And once the yeast
starts working,
it's going to start creating
all those byproducts
that we talked
about, and then you
end up with beer afterwards.
There are some more
steps that we could
talk forever and ever about.
But basically after
that, you're going
to dry hop it is the most
important one that I want
to talk about, since
hop forward beers are
very popular in Southern
California, especially.
And dry hopping means you--
it's very confusing, because
there's nothing dry about it--
but you're basically taking a
bunch of hops, at the very end,
after the beer has
been fermented.
It's ready to roll.
It could head over to
the filtration area
if you wanted it
to, but instead, you
throw a whole bunch
of hops in there.
And the reason why is so we can
get the other part of the hop
out, the essential oil out.
And this is where the
majority, the large majority,
of all the hop aroma that you
smell in a hop forward beer
is going to come
from, the dry hop.
So post fermentation hopping,
dump a bunch hops in there,
you get all those
beautiful aromas,
just like you guys
got to smell earlier.
After that, we're going to take
the beer into the filtration
area, and here you can do all
kinds of different features
to filter the beer.
We can put it through
a centrifuge which
is just a light filtration
to it, a machine that
spins around really quickly
and takes out any major solids.
We can also send it
through a plate and frame
filter which is charged with
diatomaceous earth which
are made up of little
ground up diatoms
that help trap spent yeast
and other protein bonds.
And what that means
in basic terminology
is that it makes the beer clear,
because protein bonds, proteins
that bond together is
what makes beer cloudy,
in its most basic terms.
So if you have a very
highly hopped beer or lots
of yeast residue or
things like that,
that's what makes a beer cloudy.
And by sending it through this
diatomaceous earth filter,
it strips those out.
Some people think that it strips
out some flavor, and that's
definitely true, some flavor
and aroma, it's definitely true.
But there's also a shelf life
and a stability advantage
to stripping your
beer down very clear.
It doesn't mean that it has to
be-- some beers have just less
stuff going on in them,
and you can send it just
through the
centrifuge and end up
with a fairly clear
beer that doesn't
go through a heavy polish.
And some beer needs to really
go through that heavy polish.
It also depends on
the style of the beer.
Some beers are meant to be
very cloudy in appearance,
and some beers should
look bright and clear.
That's just the way that it is.
OK, yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVE ADAMS: The question was
is that where the body the beer
comes from?
No, not necessarily.
It does have a
role to play in it,
but the body will mostly
come from the residual sugar
content that's in the beer,
the alcohol content that's
in the beer.
The effervescence of the beer
is very important to the body.
I mean, even to
the degree where it
can make a beer taste
much lighter in alcohol
or much heavier in alcohol.
If you had a beer that was 9%
alcohol that had a bunch of CO2
in it, you would think that
it's maybe 7% in alcohol.
So a lot of the body comes
from those characteristics.
There can be some
body that comes
from less filtration
or more filtration,
but usually that's not good.
If you're picking up body
qualities from not filtering,
it's usually a chalky
quality, because you
have too much particulate
that's leftover in there.
So there's a lot of
those, like the beers
nowadays, like the hazy IPAs and
things like that, some of those
are coming from the mineral
content in the water,
and it's interaction with the
yeast and things like that.
But if you're getting
it because you're just
leaving a bunch of
sludge in the beer,
then that's not a
good way to do it.
And it's not a
good representation
of the beer afterwards,
and it also really
hurts shelf life quite a bit.
So it's perfectly fine to
unfilter your beer completely,
but all you have-- it's really
hard to make a super cloudy
beer on purpose,
because if you just
let it sit in the tank
for a couple of days.
It really just
settles out by itself,
and it becomes a relatively
clear beer after that.
So you've got to really
go out of your way
to make a very
muddy, sludgy beer.
And if you're doing it the
right way, it can add some--
what it will do is just not
take away any of the aroma.
So really those beers that are
like the hazy, murky IPAs--
or whatever you
want to call them--
they are beers that have low
bitterness and high, dry hop
qualities and are not filtered
very much, and that's it.
OK, any other questions
about the brewing process?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: When do they
add the cilantro or any
of the other ingredients?
DAVE ADAMS: Yeah, good question.
The question was, when do
they add spices to the beers?
You mentioned cilantro.
Usually, you'll see
things like orange peel
and grains of paradise
and things like that.
Most of those are added
in the whirlpool addition,
or you can add them
post fermentation,
similar to dry hopping.
And the reason why you
do them a different way
is because, basically, if
they're aseptic or not.
So if you have it or if
it's already aseptic,
and it has no bacterial
contamination,
you can add it in
post fermentation.
But if you're going
to add something
in post fermentation that
hasn't been sterilized already,
then you have the chance of
bacterial contamination, which
is why you wouldn't do that.
And that's when you add it
into the whirlpool side,
because it will sterilize the
ingredients that you're using.
But if they're
delicate ingredients
it could also not
get the flavors
that you want out of
it because of that.
AUDIENCE: How do you control
the yeast of a wild beer?
DAVE ADAMS: Yeah, good question.
The question was how do you
control the yeast of a wild
beer, and the answer is
pretty much, you don't.
You can control it with
the amount that you pitch,
and you control it
with the sugar content.
You can control it
with the temperature,
just like you would
any other yeast,
but it can be
difficult to control
and they do kind of have a
mind of their own at times.
It's not as difficult as
working with bacteria,
especially pediococcus But
like lactobacillus delbrueckii
that you'll see in a lot
of kettle-soured beers
and a lot of just
most sour beers
in general use
lactobacillus delbrueckii.
That is fairly easy
to control, but I
would say that it's
a sliding scale of--
or that the scale
ramps up in volume
from like Brettanomyces,
that wild yeast strain,
would be here, and then
it would be lactobacillus
and then it would be
pediococcus after that.
Those get much more difficult
as you go up into the bacteria
phase of things.
Especially because they interact
with each other and other
ingredients in the beer,
and they're just overall
a real pain in the ass.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: How come sterilization
is not a problem when
you do the dry hopping?
You talked about throwing other
random things [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVE ADAMS: Yeah, good question.
The question was how come
throwing a bunch of hops
in post fermentation doesn't
cause a bunch trouble?
The hops are already
fairly sterilized,
and they also have
anti-microbial and
anti-bacterial
qualities to them,
and they were actually
originally used
in beer for that
specific quality.
Actually even today,
lambic-style beers,
which are naturally,
spontaneously fermented
beers from the Lambic
region of Belgium, which
are very rare and
hard to find and taste
really weird and
funky, and they have
tons of different wild
yeasts and bacteria in them.
They don't have any hints of
west coast-style hop profiles
to them.
They use tons of
hops in their beer,
but they're all aged hops.
So they just let them sit out,
and then all the acids and oils
get out of them, and
they only use them
for preservative qualities.
Other questions?
Sensory evaluation, what
we all want to talk about.
So we're basically going to go
through the whole sensory part
for everybody that's
watching, and then we're
going to break from presentation
and go drink beer after that.
I hope that works for everybody.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVE ADAMS: OK, great.
All right, so sensory
evaluation, before we get
started the reason why I think
that this is very important
is because we all drink beer.
And we all drink stuff
and eat stuff in general.
Right?
And I really want--
I think that there's a severe
lack of good vocabulary
out there when talking
about these types of things
that we ingest.
And a lot of times,
I hear things
like good, bad, gross,
I don't like it,
stuff like that, all stuff
that sounds really dumb.
So we're going to try to
not sound really dumb.
And I'm going to give you a
whole bunch of fun descriptors,
and I really want to teach
everybody in the room
that it's very easy
to describe things,
if you think about
them critically, almost
regardless of your background.
Now, it does help--
there is a caveat--
does help if you're
an adventurous person
who likes to travel,
not a picky eater, not a
drinker, things like that.
Because you'll just have more
life experiences and more
descriptors to pull from.
If you're somebody who only eats
hamburgers and French fries,
and you get it plain every time.
Or you order something
a specific way,
and that's the only
thing you eat forever,
for your whole life.
You always get a Caesar
salad with the sauce
on the side and the
croutons, there's only three
of them placed on the
right side of the plate
and things like that.
If you're that kind of
person, it is harder to do,
but it doesn't mean
that you can't do it.
And a lot of the
descriptors will actually
come from just the
environment of you
walking around and
smelling your environment
and noticing your environment,
be it trees or ground or rain
or all these kind of
senses that come to you,
especially from an
aromatic standpoint.
You learn that that's a
very important part of it.
But the idea is
that a lot of people
think, especially
from a wine world--
Has anybody done a wine
tasting in here before?
OK.
So especially like from
the wine side of things,
I think that they really like
to pull out the flavor wheel
and use a lot of terminology
that you would only
use if you are
talking to industry
professionals about wine.
And I think that's
completely useless,
unless you are an industry
professional about wine.
So I like to teach
sensory to the public,
from the sense that they're all
descriptors that we all know,
that we can all talk about.
Because it makes sense
and it's more relevant
if you're out having
dinner with someone,
or you're out at a
bar with your friends.
These are all words that
we would use all the time
and totally know exactly what
they mean without saying,
you know, something
weird that would only
be used for a specific
scientific purpose that's
only inside of the brewhouse.
No point in saying
something like that.
Right?
So that's the idea.
So I'm going to walk
you through is really
the structure of how
I like to taste beer,
how I like to break it down.
And we're going to do a very
kind of regimented version
of this tasting.
But it doesn't
mean that you have
to crack out a pen and paper
every single time that you
taste something or eat something
or you're out at dinner.
What it means is just to think
about things in this manner,
and you will have a better and
easier way of describing them.
Which makes you
a better consumer
ultimately and
just more educated
in general about the
things that you ingest.
Right?
OK, so first thing is going to
be the appearance of the beer.
So we want to think of
colors, like golden, amber.
We want to avoid using
the terms light in dark,
because they're really
junky descriptors.
So think of a Crayola
box, think of the rainbow,
think of colors of things
that you see out in the world,
and those are more
fun descriptors.
And also keep in mind,
whenever you're making
these descriptors, the more--
I call them the prime number
of the explanation, which
means keep digging
down until it's
the last thing that you can
think of in that explanation.
So for example,
if you say hoppy,
the reason why I don't
like saying hoppy
is because what kind of
hops are you talking about?
And when in the brewing
process did you use them,
and are you talking about
bitterness or flavor or aroma?
Right?
There's a litany of things
that we could talk about.
If we say hoppy, it's
such a loaded descriptor.
So what I really would
rather have you say
is it smells like
standing in a wet forest,
or it smells like
freshly grated lime zest.
That is a prime
descriptor right there.
You are digging down to the
furthest that you can go.
So you can replace hoppy
with that kind of a thing,
and the same thing
goes with citrus.
The same thing goes with
floral, and it's the same reason
why saying good, bad,
light, and dark all suck.
Because they are not good
descriptors of things,
because there are
way more detailed
than better descriptors of them.
OK?
So think of your creative
writing class out there.
You're all creative people.
Make it happen.
Head retention will
be another one.
So this will just be how long
the head stays on the beer.
So I'll pour a
little bit of beer
here, so you can see
what I'm talking about.
So we see that there is a nice,
fluffy, white head on the beer.
Also, just quickly,
head is part of beer.
So if you ever put
your finger in here,
or you blow it off or knock
it off or something like that,
stop doing that.
It's part of the beer.
You drink it.
OK?
So we see how long this
sticks around on there.
That is our head retention.
So we say it's a fluffy,
bright, white head that
dissipated about
half way quickly,
and the rest of it stuck around.
Great, perfect.
Next will be the
clarity of the beer.
This beer, for example, has
a slight haze to it, right,
not so crystal clear.
It's got a little
haziness, and we just
want to mention something
along those lines.
Is it bright?
Is it crisp?
Is it clear?
Is it opaque in color?
Is it hazy, but light in color?
All of those things.
OK?
The next part is the aroma.
This is where I want you to
spend the majority of your time
evaluating the aroma.
So there's a couple of different
parts of our olfactory system.
There is-- what do you think of?
What part of your body think
of when you think of aroma?
AUDIENCE: Nose.
DAVE ADAMS: You think
of your nose, right?
Pretty obvious, but
the fact of the matter
is that you have an
orthonasal and a retronasal.
Your orthonasal is
your nose, and that's
where you get some aroma
from, and your retronasal
is in the back of
your throat, that's
connected to your nose, or
your nasal cavity, really.
And that's where you get
a bunch of aroma from too.
So a lot of times, what
we think of as humans--
and some people may have been
taught this in school too--
that when you smell something,
you smell with your nose.
And when you put something in
your mouth, it becomes a taste.
Right?
Well, that's not the way
that it works at all.
You're evaluating the
taste and the aroma
at the same time when you
have something in your mouth.
You just don't know it.
And the easiest way to
describe this to you
would be, anytime that
you've ever been sick before
and had a stuffed up nose,
and have you ever said, man, I
can't taste anything.
Right?
We've all said that.
Everyone shake
their head, dammit.
We've all said that
before in our lives.
Right?
That's because our retronasal
is closed at that time.
So we're not getting
a bunch of aroma.
It's not that we
can't taste things.
Our taste buds still work fine.
It's just that we can only
taste five or six things,
and we can smell thousands
and thousands and thousands
of things.
Right?
So from a percentage
standpoint, can someone
figure out what's the
percentage of 5 versus 10,000?
Whatever that is is
the amount of time
that you should spend
on aroma versus taste.
All right, and I'll look
for that answer later.
Thank you.
We want to take a
short, concise breaths
as we're doing this evaluation.
So if anybody's ever taught
you to smell something before--
for the wine glass, how do they
teach you how to smell wine?
Come on, guys, you
took a wine class.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVE ADAMS: OK, you've
been out with a friend
before that's done this before.
How do people smell wine?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You smell the glass,
and you swirl it around.
DAVE ADAMS: Yeah, what kind of
breath do they take, usually?
AUDIENCE: Deep.
DAVE ADAMS: Yeah, a big,
giant, deep one, right?
Yeah.
Doesn't that look bad ass?
No.
You look stupid.
So the reason why
we don't do that
is the same reason
why dogs don't
take big giant breaths
in, and they take
little tiny short breaths in.
It's because it dries
out your nasal cavity,
so it's no good for
evaluating things.
So when we take
breaths of things
in to evaluate the
orthonasal portion of it,
we want to take small, short
breaths, just like a dog would.
So I like to smell it, pull it
away, smell it, pull it away,
smell it, pull it away, and
keep going till I get everything
that I can out of it.
Swirling will help agitate
and volatilized the aromas
that are in the glass.
So if you're having
trouble, because we're
using these little glasses
as we're going to taste.
So at home if you're
doing this, you
want to use the biggest
most open, big wine glass,
stem glass.
I should mention that while
we're talking about aroma.
The glass for beer that
you've all seen out there,
for some reason we got
the shitty glass out
of all the different types
of liquor in the world.
The beer glass is the
worst glass in the world.
So just throw all your beer
glasses in the trash can
and go buy wine glasses.
They're are way better for
evaluating beer and just really
drinking out of in general.
They're just better.
So if you need to have
water glasses at your house,
keep those pint glasses in your
cupboard, and you can do that.
And all the rest of them you
can throw off your balcony
and call it a day.
And then go buy wine glasses,
and pour all the stuff
inside of those.
OK?
And then you swirl that
around and smell those, that's
really what you want to do.
OK?
Next, talk about that,
10,000 different aromas.
Look, exclamation mark.
Take your time.
So please, this
is the time that I
need you to focus on the
most, the most important.
You should have lots of words
written for this portion if it.
The other ones
will be very short.
When you talk about the
appearance of the beer,
when you're talking about the
taste and aftertaste and all
those things, but
the aroma, this
is where your creative writing
really comes into play.
Think of the food, environment,
memories was something
that we didn't talk about.
If you like let's say you had an
orange tree in your front yard
when you were a kid, and this
reminds you of being at home.
For me, I had a pepper
tree in my front yard.
So anytime I have things with
peppercorns, peppercorn sauces,
you know peppercorn sauce
on a steak, salad, whatever
it may be, beers that have it.
It reminds me of being at home,
because I had a big pepper
tree in my front yard.
So you can associate
those kind of memories.
You know maybe you walked
by a rosebush every day
from your grandma's house
when you went to school.
So the beer reminds you of
being at grandma's house
and going to school.
That's cool.
All right, taste
is the next part.
So this is where people
get very confused.
Taste is the portion
of your tongue
and all the receptors around
your cheeks and whatnot,
and you can only detect a
very small amount of qualities
from taste.
Here they are-- sweet,
sour, salty, bitter, umami,
and then if it's none
of these, it's an aroma.
So a lot of times, matter
of fact, every single time
I've done this class, which
is probably 150 times,
there's always been one
person, at the very least,
who's written an aroma
in the taste section.
Don't be that person.
You can be my first class
who doesn't do that.
I'll be so happy.
And it's very hard
to do, because like I
said, we're all taught to, when
we take a sip of something,
it becomes the
taste immediately.
So you think, as soon as you
put the beer into your mouth,
everything that you can think
of in your brain at that point
becomes taste.
This is just not true,
because if it is not
one of those things,
it's not a taste.
That's it, period.
So does that mean that
you only describe it
as sweet, sour,
salty, umami, bitter?
No, it doesn't.
It means be creative,
have fun, you still
want some creative
input on this.
And what I like to do
is use one qualitative
and one quantitative
descriptor in front of a taste.
So what I mean by
that is you give
a level of whatever
the quality is,
like let's say it's
bitter for example.
So I would say a qualitative
example like pine
and a quantitative example like
high, aggressive, moderate,
low, medium, and then say
the taste descriptor, bitter.
So it has a piney,
aggressive bitterness.
It has a moderate, caramel
sweetness, something like that.
Make sense?
OK.
Next, after taste
and mouth feel.
So here, we're going
to be judging whatever
we are detecting in our mouths.
So the viscosity of the
beer, how thick is the beer,
is it like a brandy?
Is it coating your
mouth, or is it
like a champagne that
wafts away very quickly
and is very
effervescent and bubbly.
The effervescence
is a big part of it.
We talked about that earlier.
If it's a highly
effervescent beer,
it will seem much more
lighter on your palate.
Lingering flavors, any
bitterness, any sweetness,
any roastiness that
lingers around,
mention it here in the
aftertaste and the mouthfeel,
and that's it.
Cheers.
OK, any more questions
before we start tasting?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why is beer
so warm in Germany?
DAVE ADAMS: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: In Germany,
beers are so warm.
DAVE ADAMS: Long?
AUDIENCE: Warm.
DAVE ADAMS: Warm,
I'm sorry, thank you.
The question was why are the
beers so warm in Germany?
So first of all, the beer
should not be warm in Germany.
So you probably didn't have
very good beer over there.
The beer in Europe
sometimes can be
served at cellar
temperature, which
is 50 to 55 degrees Fahrenheit.
So it depends on
how you drink beer.
But sometimes we are sort of
maybe programmed, if you will,
to drink beer at a
very cold temperature,
maybe because of some one
brewery who makes commercials
about trains and ice mountains.
But other than that, you
should not be drinking beer
at super cold temperatures.
And the reason why is
because all those aromas,
they do not come out into
the air at cold temperatures,
or into your mouth,
for that matter,
or into your nasal cavity.
So when you drink beer, it
should be at that 50 to 55
degree range, especially
if you're evaluating it.
I mean, there are certain things
to be said about preference.
Like if you love your beer
super ice cold, then whatever,
drink it super ice cold.
But just know that you're
not getting as much flavor
and aroma out of it as if you
drank it a few degrees warmer.
So as a rule of thumb,
usually, I like it
at about 45 degrees or so.
If I'm really like diving in
and judging beer or something,
we almost always have
it at 50, 55 degrees.
There you go.
What else?
Ready to drink beer?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVE ADAMS: OK, peace.
[APPLAUSE]